virtues of being a nerd in the modern
world is that we're taken over the world
and when you look at all the comic book
movies that are currently slated for
release comic books used to be a sort of
nerd preserve now they're not now the
nerd is the mainstream this is that this
is the great liberation of the Nerds
this is the liberation of the Nerds
Simon Pegg will be our leader he will be
the light and what's up what'd he say he
thinks we've been infantilize by our own
tastes let me pay came under fire for
some controversial statements he made
about the current state of nerd dumb now
we're essentially all consuming very
childish things comic book superheroes
adults are watching this stuff and
taking it seriously no uh-huh I just
have some real issues with the Marvel
phase three lineup I don't think the
Black Panther shadow what would you just
do the episode please fine Simon Pegg
harkens back to a pre Star Wars past
where quote films used to be about
challenging emotional journeys and moral
questions like The Godfather a taxi
driver Bonnie and Clyde the French
Connection gritty amoral art movies but
Simon you're in Star Trek you're in
Shaun of the Dead about two losers
during the zombie apocalypse and then
Hot Fuzz about boys playing with guns
and then the worlds end which is about
this very problem of not growing up oh
my god there's a theme to all his work
you make some pretty bold statements
we're made passionate about the things
that occupied us as children as a means
of drawing our attentions away from the
things that we really should be invested
in inequality corruption economic
injustice etc etc etc etc okay I think
we got it got it assignment is worried
that people are more concerned with the
marvel casting or what hats are Team
Fortress 2 characters get or when the
next Call of Duty game comes out and not
that elephants are going extinct Anglo
bubble warming is irreversible and the
widening wealth gap the internet heard
his comments and took it surprisingly
well I'm just kidding there was a nerd
rage all over the place
even some reporters weren't into it he's
ignoring the bigger picture comic book
adaptations aren't totally devoid of
deep meaning nor do they threaten the
challenging filmmaking says David sim
who I think promised sounds exactly like
that Pegg quickly posted a blog in his
website to help clarify his comments but
basically boil down to oh no no no I
still like all that stuff you do it's
great but I do think it's making us a
society of children we call Internet
in his rebuttal he does name drop some
movies like ex machina and Mad Max that
satisfy our nerd boners while still
being thought-provoking and original but
for the most part he's insistent that
there's a pretty wide gap between the
stuff that's good for us and the stuff
we like and for him that's a problem
now whatever side of the debate you fall
on it's interesting to hear some honesty
from one of the Titans of the nerd
industrial complex I think that the best
outcome for this would probably be not
doing away with all the movies and TV
shows we love but rather holding them to
a higher standard
who knows maybe when they make another
Hulk movie it'll be an allegory for the
plight of the endangered giant panda
Hulk smash poachers so what are your
thoughts internet we'd love to get your
opinion leave a comment telling us what
you think about simon's comments and be
sure to subscribe to new media rockstars
for new thought-provoking videos and
also videos about tacos lots of videos
about tacos I'm drew Coolidge and you
know what is infantilizing our culture
my mom posting those pictures of me on
her Facebook I'm a big boy now
[Music]